Hey, kids, welcome back.
I thought we'd kick off this lesson in
one of my favorite spots in Atlanta,
Piedmont Park.
This area used to be
a dilapidated fairground, but
then sometime in the early 1900s it
was transformed into the lovely and
public open space that you see today.
This transformation, by the way,
was done by the Brothers Olmsted, sons
of Frederick Law Olmsted whom you might
know as the lead landscape architect
of Central Park in New York City.
Okay.
But why are we here?
Well, this lesson is about parallelizing
computations on the heart and
soul of computer science
data structures, the tree.
You're going to learn
a bunch of tricks for
extracting parallelism
from tree computations.
These include, for example, taking
the tree, converting it into a line, and
then parallelizing
operations on the line.
Now at some point in this process,
you and
I are going to get a little bit stuck.
So instead of trying to figure out
what to do, we're going to reach for
a classic trick in the lazy
computer scientist's tool box.
It's called randomization or
more simply flipping coins.
Lucky me.
In addition to the video,
there is also a reading.
So be sure that you do both, and
while you're busy doing that,
I'm going to go off and feed
the ducks which is probably illegal.
And then I'm going to take a nap.
Good luck to you and
wake me when you are done.
[MUSIC]